with so many small electronic devices on
the market there's a constant demand for
charges shops like this one in paris
sell the three models that are available
in the european union but soon they'll
only need to sell one because under new
eu rules manufacturers will have to
produce the same standard charger
it's a very good idea if something works
then it's better for us we're here to
sell
the new legislation means that across
the european union phone chargers and
small electronic devices will all have
to use the usbc connector that means
that the micro usb
and the lightning become obsolete
us tech giant apple had fiercely opposed
the idea of a standard charger the
company's devices mainly use its
custom-made lightning connector apple
said that a universal charger would
stifle innovation and create waste as
people would be forced to discard cables
but the eu says that the measure is
aimed at reducing waste this agreement
that we reached today is a very
important agreement which is giving
a fairer
deal to our consumers but it is also
giving a fairer deal to our environment
because ultimately we are producing
between 13 to 15 000 tons of electronic
waste
of charges that we barely ever use
the block estimates that consumers in
europe spend nearly three billion
dollars each year on a variety of
charges so a standard model could make
life cheaper as well as simpler for most
people
economically and environmentally it
makes sense it suits everyone it should
be done
if there's a standard charger we won't
have to shop all the time for another
one it's a brilliant idea and it'll save
money
it's taken the eu a decade to reach an
agreement on the universal charger which
will become mandatory in 2024. the block
is now working on implementing a
standard charger for larger electronic
devices including laptops by 2026
natasha butler al jazeera paris